[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact conservationists in China
are on an urgent quest hoping to find a
turtle
not just any turtle but the rarest
turtle in the world
Yangtze softshell turtles also called
red river turtles are the largest
freshwater turtles in the world found
only in Vietnam and China they can live
for over a hundred years and grow to be
nearly 200 pounds but sadly these giant
river turtles are now the most
endangered species in the world there
are only three known living specimens
left two are in captivity at that show
zoo zoo and one illusive male lives in a
lake in Vietnam dam construction and
urban development have pushed the rare
creatures to the brink of extinction
scientists have tried three times to
breathe the living pair but without
success they believe if they can find
one or two more it will greatly increase
the hopes that this species could
survive otherwise the Yangtze soft shirt
turtles are destined to go the way of
the dodo you know the Bible says one of
the signs of the last days is that
mankind would have the capacity to
destroy the earth don't go anywhere
friends we'll learn more as we talk
about it on this edition of Bible
answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 free phone
call one eight hundred four six three
seven two nine seven that's 800 god says
800 four six three seven 297 my name is
Doug Batchelor my name is John Ross good
evening friends and pastor Doug let's
stop the program with prayer dear father
once again we are grateful that we have
this opportunity to talk about your word
and we pray that you'd be with us as we
open up the scriptures and look for
Bible answers thank you Father for the
opportunity I have so many tuning and
listen around the world and we ask your
blessing upon this time in Jesus name
Amen amen
hope acid are you open the program
they're talking about a very rare turtle
and a couple of interesting things you
mentioned it's one of the largest or the
largest freshwater turtle but it also
lists over a hundred years now of course
we do know of some tortoises that live
well over a hundred years but the
problem of this particular species they
write down to just three left
but the no.of yeah and you know they
don't know enough about these turtles
there's one wild one in Vietnam and
they're not even sure if it's a male or
female because they're hard to catch and
it's hard to determine with some turtles
but yeah unless and the one male that
they've gotten the zoo is he's like 80
years old so then honey sure how vero
he is so they're doing their best to try
to get the female to have a clutch of
eggs and they think then they can try to
bring it back if not it'll go extinct
but it'll be added to the list of about
500 species that have gone extinct in
the last hundred years I just read a
fact that said humanity has wiped out
60% of mammals birds fish and reptiles
since 1970 you know you can clearly see
that through the industrialization and
the sprawl of of construction that it is
having an impact on nature but you know
the Bible foretold that would happen
jesus said in Matthew 24 that unless the
days are shortened no flesh would be
saved but for the elects sake those days
will be shortened and speaking about
conditions in the last days and then
revelation 18 I'm sorry revelation 11:18
the nations were angry in your wrath has
come and the time of the Dead that they
should be judged and that you should
reward your servants the prophets in the
Saints and those who fear your name
small and great and listen to this part
and you should destroy those who destroy
the earth now that's an interesting
statement at the end there destroy those
that destroy the earth because if you go
back to just my grandfather when he was
born the most dangerous weapons that man
had was a cannonball I mean you know a
big bullet and that's all that you do
and you could fire a million of those
you're not gonna destroy the earth but
now with the the chemical developments
and with the pollution and with what's
going into the air and with nuclear
weapons
you know man really has the ability to
destroy the earth now I think the Lord
is going to come first because jesus
said except those days be shortened
there'd be no flesh then that word flesh
there means no life so I made human or
animal and so that gives us one more
reason to think that Jesus is coming
soon now we have a free offer that talks
about living in the last days and being
ready for the last days and why don't
you tell us about that
it's book entitled the last night on
earth and took some certain events that
will take place close to the coming of
Jesus more importantly how
we be ready for Jesus to come that is a
free offer we'll be happy to send this
to anyone who calls and asks the number
to call is 808 three five six seven four
seven and you can ask for the book
called the last night on earth
and we'll be happy to send that to
anyone in North America you can also
read it by going to the amazing facts
website just amazing facts dot-com org
and if you have a Bible question our
phone line here the studio is eight
hundred four six three seven two nine
seven pastored I would also like to
greet our friends joining us on Facebook
we have folks at the amazing facts
Facebook page your Facebook page and I
know people are watching all around the
world and they tune in and they
participate in Bible answers life so if
our friends are watching on Facebook if
you have a Bible question again if you
North America give us a call the number
is eight hundred four six three seven
two nine seven ready to go to the phone
lines our first caller this evening is
Andrea and we're listening in Tennessee
and we welcome to the program Andrew
you're on the air hello pastor doug and
pastor ross i have a question
found in first timothy chapter four
verse one through five and if you could
clarify something about that because
recently I've discovered that the
longest people in the world longing to
live people in the world are vegan or
vegetarian and so I started changing the
way that I eat and this and then I had
several people in the church use this
verse to point to me that I'm not
supposed to be a vegan or vegetarian
well this verse certainly doesn't say
that you shouldn't be a vegan or
vegetarian let me read it for our
friends that are listening they're
probably sixty percent of our listeners
are on the road right now now the spirit
speaks expressly saying that in latter
times and by the way this is first
Timothy chapter 4 on beginning with
verse one in latter times some will
depart from the faith giving heed to
deceiving spirits and doctrines of
devils speaking lies in hypocrisy having
their own conscience seared with a hot
iron and forbidding to marry and
commanding to abstain from foods that
God has created to be received with
Thanksgiving now right there they're
saying this group is going
command to abstain from foods that God
said could be cracy with Thanksgiving
and also forbidding to marry so these
are two clues about the same group well
there is a large church that says you
shouldn't need certain foods in certain
days of the week and their their
ministry is not allowed to marry it's
not saying that there's no benefit in
vegetarian food or being careful what
you eat cuz I think we all know that God
says whatever you sow your gonna reap
God is not mocked and if a person knows
that evening the high cholesterol blight
is gonna hurt your heart you can't say
well I'm just gonna pray over you know
deep fried Twinkies and God's gonna
bless it and you know I know people that
believe that but the Bible doesn't teach
that the Bible says do not tempt the
Lord if he knows something that is not
good for you well then don't eat it so
and it goes on it says for every
creature of God is good and nothing to
be refused if it's received with
Thanksgiving for it is sanctified by the
Word of God and prayer Nepal is talking
about people that are also saying that
you can't eat certain foods that were
sacrificed in the marketplace because
someone offered it to a pagan God before
you bought it but it might be clean food
such as you know chicken or a goat or a
lamb or something it had nothing to do
with the unclean foods because it says
these are the foods sanctified by the
Word of God it's not telling us that you
know you can't do things if you want to
be a vegetarian and to try to be
healthier you're gonna have benefits
video Adam and Eve were vegetarians and
they live 900 years so I mean that's
pretty biblical and in heaven we're all
vegetarians we'll eat from the tree of
life the lion will lay down with the ox
and the calf and the wolf with the lamb
they're not going to eat each other
nothing will die there so yeah I think
it's misunderstanding the verse to say
that this is saying that you have to eat
meat
thank you appreciate your question
Andrew I hope that helps a little bit
thank you you're good thank you yeah and
you know we've got a study guide that
has a lot more scriptures on this will
send you it's called God's free health
plan the number to call for that is
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven and again as for the study
guide called God's free health plan
we'll be happy to send it to anyone who
wants to learn
what does the Bible have to say about
health and health principles again that
number is 885 six seven four seven our
next caller that we have is Darrell and
he's listening from Arizona Darrell
welcome to the program hello pastor
Bachelor and pastor Ross I appreciate
you guys taking my question thanks for
calling yeah no problem I I just have a
question regarding cremation on whether
or not it's really right and proper for
a Christian to be buried or be cremated
or if it doesn't matter well that's a
good question I don't want to say it
doesn't matter because I think everyone
needs to decide and just let the Lord
lead them will tell you what the Bible
says there is no command that you have
to be buried or that you are not allowed
to be cremated but there is strong
circumstantial evidence that the Bible
method was traditionally burial you know
some of the pagans they would cremate
their dead and pastor Ross and I've been
to India you were there what just a few
weeks ago yeah earlier this year yeah
and we've seen you know people being
cremated it's kind of a disturbing sight
on the street
typically you look in the Bible Abraham
Isaac Jacob David they were buried with
their fathers it was a traditional
buried burial some were embalmed and
buried like Jacob was embalmed by Joseph
and Joseph was embalmed and then they
were brought to the promised land and
buried there are examples of a couple of
people that were cremated not so much by
choice but because they you know we're
what's it mutilated in war and that
would be King Saul and Jonathan now we
know at least Jonathan will be in heaven
so cremation does not prevent the Lord
from resurrecting anybody because the
Bible tells us that ashes to ashes and
dust to dust so when a person dies and
they're buried unless they're very
carefully embalmed you know body turns
back to the elements of the earth God is
not coming back for during the
resurrection and saying I did give up I
can't find all the parts to resurrect
them it's not gonna be a problem for God
because he's making all things new so
you know for those who have been
cremated it's not an obstacle to God
resurrecting them but the Bible
traditionally shows
that people were buried so that's a long
answer I hope that helps a little bit
Darryl yes sir I appreciate it thank you
very much all right hey thanks so much
and who do we have next
next caller that we have is e Frank
listening from New York Frank welcome to
the program yes
good evening pastor Doug and pastor Ross
I'm calling this evening your show
because I'm very curious to find out if
it's fair and justified to actually
believe that by looking into the heavens
you know you can actually discover the
full sphere of who God is because I've
read several verses in scripture that
says that in the heavens God manifests
himself upon the earth and I don't
really understand that too well well I
I'm trying to remember that Psalm 19
yeah Psalm 19 verse 1 it says the
heavens declare the glory of God and the
firmament showeth these handiwork when I
think what David is saying in this Psalm
is that when you look at the heavens and
you see the majesty and you see the
incredible you know the numberless stars
it's interesting that some of the
ancients thought they could count the
stars they thought they're about 5,000
119 stars but he got to labrum that
they're numberless like the sand
well now scientists say there are about
as many stars as there are grains of
sand on the world and so God was exactly
right when he said it was numberless but
you can't see God you can see something
about him from his creation and in the
book of Job it says you know you
consider the asking the cattle and they
will tell you and ask the birds and they
will tell you and through looking at the
things of God you can see something
about God and His creative power and his
character but you can't look through a
telescope and see a picture of God's
face well you know when I hear stories
about Voyager 2 leaving our
interplanetary universe and things of
that nature I always come to the
conclusion that God is very vast and our
understanding of our knowledge but he
also you know
is limited in how he expresses himself
through his other creations so that's
why I was very curious to have call this
evening your show because you know there
are many other people who scientifically
like Carl Sagan and others who've said
things that really don't are in
accordance with Holy Scripture no I
think you're absolutely right
you know there's a lot we can learn
about God through the things that he's
made matter of fact we have a book I
think you'd enjoy it's on the wonders of
creation it talks about how you can see
God through your through his creation if
you'd like to receive that book just
give us a call the number is 883 five
six seven four seven and you can after
the book talking about the wonders of
creation again the number is 883 five
six seven four seven enjoy incredible
facts and inspiring spiritual lessons in
a world of wonders daily devotional with
facts from nature science history
technology and more it's great for the
whole family get yours today by calling
855-578-6767 other-- guy
you have to worship me instead of God
for 30 days and Daniel said that breaks
one of the Ten Commandments we're not
going to in the last days it's been
presumed that the devil is going to say
all right well I'm gonna be very clever
I'm going to say that you you need to
break the fourth commandment regarding
the Sabbath and so a lot of folks are
speculating well if there's gonna be a
law a Sunday law well from in North
America and even in Europe probably
another number of the other countries
that were colonized there are already
many Sunday laws in the books most of
them aren't enforced somewhere I
actually I knew a man that was he was
put in jail for working out in the field
on Sunday years ago in Canada mm-hmm
they used to enforce those but it's a
belief that around the country at some
point they're going to make a National
Sunday law and compel people to go to
church you know a lot of folks are
looking at what's happening in society
things are so divided politically it
seems like you've got the humanism
pushing against Christianity and folks
are thinking maybe Christians are going
to get so fed up that the pendulum is
gonna swing so far the other way maybe
there'll be some national disaster or
something and people are gonna be told
you've got to go to church and worship
the way we tell you to and the beasts
power will combine with these
well-meaning folks when that might
happen I don't know no man knows the day
or the hour you know throughout history
whenever you have a religious power
using civil authority to enforce a
certain type of worship the end result
is typically persecution throughout the
Dark Ages there were nations in Europe
not only were amongst the Catholic
nations but even some of the Protestant
nations persecuted people who didn't see
things their way
so the Bible does warn us that in the
last days the issue is gonna revolve
around worship do worship God or do we
worship this beast power and yes we
think that they are going to be laws
passed at the end that restrict a
person's freedom to worship according to
God's commandments oh very interesting
question we don't know when we can see
signs fulfilled but that's something
that is yet in the future thank you for
your call Charles the next caller that
we have is Nathan listening from West
Virginia Nathan
welcome to the program hey thanks for
having me bachelors how are you all
today doing great
how are you I'm don't just want
discipline I have a question on
revelation 17 verses 9 actually 9
through 11 as it says here it says
here's the mind which has wisdom the
seven heads are the seven mountains on
which the woman sits now I understand
the woman is the church is the apostate
Church the fallen and then there are
also seven kings 5s fallen one is and
the other one has not yet come and when
he comes he must continue a short time
and then chapter verse 11 through the
Beast that was and is not is himself
also the eighth and is of the seven is
going to to perdition to destruction
that is confusing to me you know what
I'm gonna let pastor Ross I'm nothing
I'm not passing it off to him because I
don't have an answer but that's a
special study in the love of his but why
don't you take a stab at explaining this
for an Asian yeah we'll give you a
little understanding um first of all
just recognize that in Bible prophecy a
woman represents a church in Revelation
12 you have a pure woman which
represents a true church revelation 17
you have a corrupt woman which
represents a religious system that has
fallen from the commandments of God and
a number of scholars have identified
revelation 17 this woman as representing
the church during the mid arc Ages in
Europe that persecuted the Roman Church
and then it also talks about these seven
heads talks about them has been Kings
five of fallen one is and wanted you to
come a number of scholars have
identified these as those political
powers that opposed and conquered God's
people throughout history so beginning
with the Assyrian Empire they conquer
the northern tribes of Israel you have
Babel in your medo-persia of Greece you
have Rome all of these conquered Israel
and occupied God's people then you have
the sixth power which is the Roman
Church during the dark ages and then it
talks about one that is to come and when
he comes he continues a short space a
number of scholars have seen that as the
United States being the superpower in
the last days
that also begins to enforce the mark of
the beast so they see that power has
been the United States the eighth would
be the beast power which receives the
deadly wound and is healed that again
being the Roman Church in particularly
during the Dark Ages
okay now would a jiffy also a part of
them part of the five that were so on as
well well some sometimes see it that way
it could be but I like the
interpretation of these being powers
that actually conquered God's people and
occupied their land Egypt never occupied
the land they didn't of course the Jews
were captive in Egypt but they came out
of Egypt and God gave them the Promised
Land but these other powers beginning
with the Assyrians they actually
conquered Israel conquered God's people
and their land alright well thank you so
much I appreciate that Pastor off yes
have a wonderful that's your evening
thank you good question next caller that
we have is Lee Anne listening from
Virginia hi you're only on how are you
good thank you for calling my mother and
father when your parents are elderly and
your mother has like a borderline
personality disorder narcissism and she
only wants certain children to come and
she does who want you to come tell you
not to come
treat you very badly God hold that with
you to me or her or not allow me to come
and help my father take care of her yeah
you know first of all all you can do is
do your best to try to be reconciled to
people if they don't accept that then
that's between them and God you know you
do your best to be respectful it doesn't
man honoring someone doesn't mean you
agree with them I face some of the same
issues neither of my parents were
Christians and they could be very
difficult but I was always after I
became a Christian I thought the best
way I can witness to them is being kind
being patient being respectful being
loving honoring them in that way now
they might tell me they Doug you know
you
a new way to cheat on your taxes and
I'll say well you know a dad I'm a
Christian I don't cheat on my taxes oh
you're an idiot but I said well I'd
respect them but I'm not gonna do what
he's telling me to do you see what I'm
saying
I sometimes is there's a line where
you've got to let your parents know I
wish I respect you but you still you
maintain your principles as a Christian
trying hard you know not being clean
I've done that thank you so much when I
questioned yeah absolutely you you just
you pray God gives you patience and
strength and I know it it it takes some
takes some doing and you know in the
process of learning to respect and honor
family members that maybe are not
converted Christians God grows us at the
same time because he teaches us to be
more patient next quality' behave is
Henry listening from New York and we
welcome to the program yes but what to
say to you
people who are saved and they don't get
the community because I don't have a
chance in heaven well thank you that's a
that's a very important question and we
appreciate your asking that and that's
the sink way now when I answer that
question I always have to be very
delicate because everybody listening
practically they know somebody that has
made a mistake and taken their own life
I think we need to be very careful to
stop short of saying that everybody
who's committed suicide is automatically
lost because you know God looks on
people's heart there may have been
chemical or medical or changes that we
don't know about we don't know the
circumstances so that final judgment
belongs to God
but in most cases when a person takes
their own life it represents a condition
of hopelessness and faithlessness and
when people lose faith it's very hard to
please God when you have no faith you
know if people who say well you know
life is hard right now so I'm gonna kill
myself and then I'll just be in the
resurrection I don't have to worry about
trouble anymore a lot of people don't
realize that if the
act of your life is self murder then
that doesn't bode well for your
salvation
instead of taking your problems away you
could wake up in the resurrection with
one more very big problem suicide is
never an answer to escape your problems
but then again you like I said you know
we we got to be careful not to say I
mean Samson when you think about as a
suicide he kind of laid his life down to
defeat the enemies of God's people so
it's something of a sacrifice but he
said let me die with the Philistines he
pushed down the building killed himself
in the process we expect to see Samson
in heaven I know a young lady that took
pills that ultimately killed her but
after she took the pills she called and
said you know I don't want to die and
the paramedics came and tried to
resuscitate her
and they couldn't will she be saved we
don't know how she prayed or what was
going on in her mind in those final
moments and you know that's what we just
need to cling to hope is all you can do
in those cases if friends were gonna
take a break and come back for more
Bible questions in just a minute
I get a drink of water tell your friends
to call up with a question we'll be back
in two minutes
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
once a know God's plan for our world and
solutions for your life's challenges
beautifully redesigned amazing facts 27
Bible study guides provide encouraging
Bible based answers to questions on
healthier relationships when Jesus will
return and much more prefer to watch
while you read our brand new prophecy
encounters DVD series makes the perfect
companion set order your study guides
and DVDs today by visiting AAF bookstore
calm or by calling 858 7275
[Music]
throughout recorded history tales of
ghosts and spirits can be found in
folklore in nearly every country and
culture the Egyptians built pyramids to
help guide the spirits of their leaders
Rome sanctioned holidays to honor and
appease the spirits of their dead even
the Bible tells of a king that used a
witch to contact the spirit of a
deceased prophet today ancient folklore
of spirits and operations have gone from
mere superstitions to mainstream
entertainment and reality scientific
organisations investigate stories of
hauntings and sightings trying to prove
once and for all the existence of ghosts
even with all the newfound technology
and centuries of stories all over the
world there is still no clear-cut answer
so how do we know what's true why do
these stories persist does it even
matter we invite you to look inside and
find out for yourself visit death truth
com every Bible question you have
answered moves you one step closer to
the fullness of God's will for your life
so what are you waiting for get the
answers you need for a fuller richer
more confident life you're listening to
Bible answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 to be kind of
quiet on if he either passed away there
or he returned to Ephesus and I was
wondering if you could shed some light
on that well you're correct the Bible is
quiet on it it does say
in Revelation that John was sent to
patent us for the Word of God he was
being punished there you need to go to
history then to find out what happened
after that and if you read in foxes Book
of Martyrs and a pretty sure Fox got
some information from some of the early
church fathers that lived in the first
150 years the tradition is that John
when that Emperor died John was then
he's you know 95 years old he lived a
long time he came back to Ephesus and he
ultimately died of old age there's one
tradition I've read that as John got
older they would actually carry him into
the church and when asked to say a word
he would always just say my little
children love one another which of
course was his theme in his letters so
it's believed that he did die in Ephesus
but you'll have to read that in foxes
Book of Martyrs I don't know if Polycarp
or one of the early church fathers talks
about that okay well thank you very much
yep have a good evening all righty thank
you next caller that we have is Becky
listening also from Michigan Becky
welcome to the program hello pastor
bachelor a whole hello pastor Sean how
are you good
and your question why is there so much
so much pain suffering in sickness in
the world
well it's the devil in a word people
think that you know if God is love then
why does he allow this well the Bible
says that God is not willing that any
should perish Jesus came to heal people
from suffering when Christ healed people
on more than one occasion he says Satan
has afflicted or Satan has bound this
pertinent Satan is the one who went to
Jobe and struck him with boils and he
struck job's family and he destroyed
job's possessions and it's kind of sad
that insurance companies if there's a
typhoon or hurricane that goes through
and destroys a house they call it an act
of God but to be biblically accurate
they would call it an act of a devil the
thing is that this world is in rebellion
to God even Jesus refers to the devil as
the prince of this world because when
our first parents chose to listen to God
instead of listen to the devil instead
of God
seyton sort of set up his office he
claimed dominion of this planet and
Jesus came to buy it back to redeem it
so there's a battle between good and
evil Christ will not force anyone to
love him and ultimately the meek will
inherit the earth and God will make a
new heaven and earth and Satan will be
destroyed but the misery is because
there is a very powerful evil maniac
rampaging around our world with his
fallen angels and they're bringing a lot
of well in misery and that's why we we
pray for God and His angels to protect
us that's why it tells us is it Psalm 91
the angel of the lord encamps round
about those that's another Psalm
actually angel net and the Psalm 91 says
he'll give his angels charge over you
another Psalm says the angel of the lord
encamps round about those that fear him
we need to pray that God will just hedge
us in with his protection from day to
day this is a world that there's a lot
of God's good in this world but the
devil has come in and and he's going
around as a roaring lion he mother story
you reference bastard egg is finally in
Luke chapter 13 you can read from verse
10 through 2 about verse 17 you have the
story of a woman that was suffering for
eighteen years
an ailment she is bent over and jesus
healed her and in response when he
healed her there was some that said I
shouldn't be doing this on the Sabbath
but Jesus said this woman that Satan had
bound these 18 years shouldn't she be
healed so and Jesus addressed her
ailment or her condition because of what
Satan had done so we live in a world and
we see the consequences of rebellion and
sin it's all around us and even Paul he
said that the devil had sent a thorn an
affliction to him so they always blame
they realize it was a devil every good
and perfect gift comes from God the
Bible says God is good and he made a
beautiful world he put Adam and Eve in
Paradise and when they chose to follow
this rebellion angel that's what all the
misery came you know we do have a study
guide called did God create a demo
perfectly deals with the subject about
the great controversy and I'll be happy
to send this to you or or anyone wanting
to know more about the subject
the number to call is 883 five six seven
four seven and again you can ask for the
study guide called did God create a
devil our next call of the behaved is
Andrea listening from Atlanta Georgia
Andrea welcome to the program thank you
very much and thank you pastors for all
you do thank you my question is why are
there so many minor prophets in the Old
Testament saying the same thing it seems
redundant am I missing something
well when the end when Andrea is talking
about the Minor Prophets you've got the
major prophets which have longer books
and they would be Ezekiel Jeremiah
Daniel and Isaiah and then the minor
prophets would be the others and that
would be Hosea Joel Amos Obadiah Jonah
Micah Nahum Habakkuk that's always fun
to say Habakkuk Zephaniah Haggai
Zechariah Malachi they really say widely
diverse things now there may be some
statements where they they repeat
themselves I mean you probably find a
few places where they you know talk
about judgment that will come if the
people don't repent Hosea
he's a very interesting prophet he talks
God tells him he's supposed to marry a
woman with a bad reputation because he
says God's people haven't been
unfaithful to me and Zechariah he's got
these apocalyptic visions and Jonah
Jonah's book of course was about a very
strange adventure going through the
digestive system of a fish and preaching
to the Ninevites so they're they're
pretty diverse books but there's a
common theme of trusting in God now most
of the minor prophets just for it not
all of them but most of them occurred
close to the Babylonian captivity and
then shortly after so when Jerusalem was
destroyed and something else interesting
most of the major prophets lived more so
during the time of the Northern Kingdom
you have Isaiah and well Jeremiah was
more of the southern kingdom but they
spoke about judgment that was coming to
the northern kingdom and then you had
the Minor Prophets relating more to
judgment they came upon
the southern kingdom and then after they
returned rebuilding the temple the
persians yeah yeah about a time period
of 300 years before the new test okay
okay that helped yeah there's just some
incredible promises in prophecies like
the last prophecy in the Old Testament
is Malachi he says remember the law of
Moses behold I send you Elijah and when
you turn into the New Testament Jesus
goes up on a mountain with Peter James
and John and Moses and Elijah appear to
him the same two Bible characters
foretold by Malachi they made some
stunning predictions that many have have
come true and who is it Zechariah that
said that the the Messiah would come
riding into Jerusalem on a donkey and
this is what Jesus did and Micah said
the Messiah would be born in Bethlehem
and that's what happened so the minor
prophets told a lot about the coming of
the Messiah we do have a book talking
about the Bible it's called the ultimate
resource and we'll give you more
information about where the Bible comes
from and a little bit more about the
divisions of the scriptures what will be
happy to send this to anyone who calls
and ask the number is 883 five six seven
four seven and again just ask for the
book called the ultimate resource and
we'll be happy to send that out Tricia
is our next caller from the Cayman
Islands
Tricia welcome to the program hi hi
thank you for calling thanks for having
me
I wanted to find out more about the
lottery and how it will affect people
who are not filled I know that it's
gonna I know the Lateran will come
around the markers at this time but I'm
unclear of how that will affect people
who are not filled alright no for our
friends are listening Tricia is talking
about in the Bible tells us that when
Christ came the first time he sent the
Holy Spirit at Pentecost the gospel
sprouted and took off like wildfire and
that was called the former rain in in
the harvesting language of Israel to
sprout the seed they had the first heavy
rains and then it would grow with
sporadic rains through the summer and
then just before the harvest they would
have the latter rains and we will
there's gonna be another outpouring of
the Holy Spirit biblically just before
Jesus comes the Lord is going to be
sealing his people during this time when
preparing them to receive the latter
rain you can read about that in
Revelation chapter 7 talks about an
angel placing a seal upon God's people
in the last days and connected with that
is the special outpouring of the Holy
Spirit just like the Christian Church
began with power at Pentecost
so in the last days there is a loud cry
that goes to all the world
yeah and Jesus is not coming back during
a time where the church is at a low
point he is gonna come back where the
church is spiritually very dedicated
walking with Him reflecting him the way
the Apostles did when he ascended to
heaven next one that we have is Marisol
from Houston Texas Marisol welcome to
the program I want to know if you don't
follow the hundred percent the
commandment but for example you like
watch action movies or you have a like
every household and but you don't read
you know cookout or you go to a club but
exactly you still don't really make that
like drink or things in particular you
know just to live life you know a little
equal are you still gonna make it Easter
doing wrong things well the when the
person disobeys one of God's
commandments
it's called sin and it doesn't matter
which commandment you know God is not
saying this month I'm giving you a 20%
discount sin is a transgression of the
law
Christ wants to save us from our sins
and all sin brings some kind of
suffering so it's not like you say well
you know I'm gonna try to obey 90% but
I'm just gonna steal a little or I'm
gonna lie a little or I'm gonna commit a
little adultery
you know God wants us to be consistent
and when we love the Lord you're not
even gonna really ask that kind of
question know what I mean by that is
you're not going to be wondering how
much of the world can I still have and
get to heaven you're gonna want to find
out Lord what pleases you when you see
that Jesus died for your sins you're
gonna see how much sin hurts him you
won't be wondering
what do I have to do you'll be saying
Lord how far can I go to please you you
know Marcio i would encourage you to
just say lord help me to understand how
much sin hurts you you know it doesn't
matter which commandment it if you're
breaking one of them it says where is it
James whoever breaks one it's guilty of
all so you know sin is sin you can't go
to the judge and you've committed murder
and you can't go to the judge and say
well look I kept the other nine
Commandments you know sir can you let me
off he wants us to be consistently
obedient now if you do sin the good news
is God is faithful to forgive you and
what I say if you send everybody
listening is sin and we all fall and
many things the Bible says but our our
goal as Christians would be to walk like
Jesus walked we do have a study guide
talking about the Ten Commandments
called written in stone and we'll be
happy to send this to anyone who calls
an ass or you can go online and read it
for free have the amazing facts website
now the phone line if you'd like to
receive a free copy of the study guide
is eight hundred eight three five six
seven four seven our next caller that we
have is serious listening from South
America service welcome to the program
hi good evening
oh yes I would like to find out about
probation I understand that you could be
alive and your probation closes no what
I was wondering is why you are alive
when your probation closes could it be
reopened now you have another chance
well the kind of her friends listen
probation closing means that the door of
mercy is shut for you an example of that
would be when Noah entered the Ark with
his family and he invited the lost
outside to enter they just mocked him
says God shut the door and life went on
outside the ark for another six or seven
days before the rain began they were
they were sealed outside there was no
more hope for them there will be a
period at the end of history where
probation closes life may go on here on
earth but the loss they're lost and the
saved are saved cyrus is wondering if a
person has their probation closes or
anything that can be done
to have it reopened I need to ask you
brother are you concerned that your
probation is closed no not at all
you know these I think that you know we
would have debates about and so on
yeah well my answer would be that if a
person's probation closes that very the
very name of it means that they have
gone beyond the point of return that
there is no more hope it's kind of like
when it says that Satan entered Satan he
went out and it was night at the Last
Supper he had grieved away the Holy
Spirit he had lost his capacity to
repent so when a person finally does
grieve away the Holy Spirit there's no
more hope for them by the way friends I
have a book on that and it's called the
unpardonable sin matter fact we get a
new edition just been printed if you'd
like to receive the book give us a call
the number is 883 five six seven four
seven and you can ask for the book on
the unpardonable sin were happy to send
that to anyone who calls and asks our
next caller that we have let's see we
have Joe listening from North Carolina
and Joe Louise thank you Dad hi how are
you doing I'm good uh I was talking to a
friend of mine tonight and we both have
the same question and the question is
and I know you've already covered it on
the show one time but it still doesn't
make sense as to why God knowing
everything before it even happens why we
what he even create us knowing that we
were going to fall and then having Jesus
to have to die what he didn't have to
all right well first of all what better
proof can God give that he will make a
creature free than to make a creature
that actually does choose not to love
him if if God said look I'm not gonna
create anybody that will not love me
then is it really love or are we just
robots at that point I I think that I I
think that you want to know that God is
good and God is love
but he makes his creatures free and that
means we have the capacity to choose not
to love him and what's happened in this
world is evidence of that yeah are you a
parent
and I've heard your explanation on that
it's just by my my thinking is like God
comes to getting hurt when he already
knew what was gonna happen yeah well did
Jesus know when he came into this world
that he was gonna die that's what I
wondered well Korea of course Christ did
from the very beginning jesus said to
his disciples I'm gonna go to Jerusalem
I'll be betrayed and I'll be crucified
God came into the world knowing full
well what was gonna happen to him but he
was willing to come into this world to
die to live a perfect life and the die
is our sacrifice because He loves us and
he wants to save us but we must be free
to love him we can choose so there he'd
not let the Garden of Eden that he was
gonna die well does God know everything
yeah
if God is all knowing that yes he even
knew well you know in the book of
Revelation it talks about Jesus as the
lamb slain from the foundation of the
world
so even when Adam and Eve right there in
the garden when they sinned there was a
sacrifice a lamb was offered they were
given coats of skin so the plan of
redemption was already available and it
just demonstrates God's love he could
have left Adam and Eve on their own and
set up you messed up let me start over
again wipe them out and creating you
Adam and Eve but God he's got a love and
he was willing to suffer himself to give
us the freedom to choose well I don't
you have other colors but I just want to
call you and ask you that question
that's fine you know what really helps
people understand we've got a DVD we've
made it's free on YouTube now just type
in cosmic conflict go to youtube type in
cosmic conflict and it explains the
whole rebellion of Lucifer and why God
had to let things go the course so
people would understand that he's a
loving God and a just God cosmic
conflict next caller that we have is
Devante listening from let's see
Virginia
Devon Terry welcome to the program hey
how you doing yes pastor awesome pastor
Doug and your question yes sir first
night first I want to say blessed I have
only father and bless our Lord Jesus
when blessed the Holy Spirit who dwells
inside amen
I'm a 25 year old young black man with
the whole
Oh sir year he meant well I'm going to
say bless y'all too fast for y'all
speaking and answering these people's
questions and people really need those
things I was I got two things to say I
was listening to the young man y'all
were just now a question about a body
Lord let Jesus died and for his first
for what he was saying because I Adam
disobeyed the Lord we were all subject
to death that's what Paul says in Romans
way that again third Paul says that in
Romans yeah that's what I'm getting to
because I Adams disobedience that's why
we subject to death but through the
obedience of Jesus Christ that's our
that's why we all gain eternal life
that's right now what's your question
before we run out of time yeah I for the
people who listened back and uh I would
like you to explain to the people how do
you know when you're saved well first of
all you come to the Lord by faith and
when we're convicted of our sins for
before you can ask for salvation you
need to know there's something we're
being safe from and went through the
Holy Spirit we are convicted of our sins
and the Bible tells us that we're
looking for life if we repent of our
sins and confess to the Lord we're
sinners Jesus came and he says look I'm
gonna come I'm gonna live a perfect
sinless life I will then die for your
sin I'll take your punishment
I will take your wickedness I will give
you my righteousness I'll take your
weakness and I'll give you my strength
I'll take the death belonged to you and
I'll give you the life that belongs to
me and we accept that by faith and when
we accept that he then gives us a new
heart and the Bible says then we're born
again and we can walk in a newness of
life and if people come to the Lord just
like they are in pray and say Lord I
believe that you are there I believe you
did that for me and we ask him he works
a miracle in our hearts that you just
can't explain now how do you know well
first of all because he said so and then
as you continue to walk with the Lord
you know because well Jesus said you'll
know them by their fruits the fruits are
different in the life and there's a joy
where there was once you know fear in
pain
you know we do have a book called
assurance justification made simple and
I think this is a great read for anyone
wanting to learn more about the subject
very important subject we'll be able to
send you the book called assurance the
number to call is eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven ask for the book assurance and
we'll be happy to send it out to anyone
who calls and asks our next call of the
behalf let's see we've got Moses
listening from El Paso Texas Moses
welcome to the program good evening
pastors how are you guys doing doing
well we got about three minutes for your
question okay really quick isn't a
question that's really bothered me it
part bit if we're in heaven it's not
gonna be any marriage or no darkness
then what's the purpose of us building
homes yeah it does say in Isaiah that
they will and I forget it's Isaiah 11 or
Isaiah 65 it's in two places
it says they'll build houses and inhabit
them and they'll plant in vineyards and
eat the fruit of them well a house is
not just to protect us from the night
and houses are not just so you can have
a family and you know a lot of kids a
home is just in a boat it's a place to
call your own people I think are gonna
have homes and write their friends over
and they'll feast together a lot of good
reasons to have a place I love building
and I was working around my house today
and just gave me a real sense of
satisfaction the verse you're referring
to as a is 65 was 21 they shall build
houses and inhabit them they shall plant
vineyards and eat the fruit of them and
those are the houses that we build out
in the country the Bible tells us Jesus
is gonna build us a house in the city
said I've gone to prepare a place for
you and so yeah people people feel
comfortable when they got their space
their home you know being collecting
their little artifacts from around the
universe I don't know but it'll be nice
and maybe we have time for one more
quick question pastor Ross all right
let's see we've got Sandra listening
from New York Sandra welcome to the
program we have just a minute yes so
real quick I just like your comment
about Genesis the Genesis chapter one
you could
compared to revelations chapter 16 the
emptying of the valves other words
there's a yeah you got your radio on in
the background it'll confuse you so you
want to know is there some color
correlation between the seven last
plagues of the vials that are poured out
in Genesis I heard one theologians say
that it almost looks like I think the
fourth plays the Sun is that right and
on the fourth day God made the Sun and
it's like the seven last plagues our
creation in Reverse it's like the world
is unraveling from the way that God made
it so I've seen we don't have time in
just a minute to go through that study
but I think you're onto something there
Sandra I've I've seen a good study that
shows that the seven last plagues that
there's something deeper deeper
happening there and of course the number
seven is significant the Bible you got
seven days of the week are created six
days rested on the seventh seven is
often a symbol of completion and so
these seven last plagues it's the last
judgment that comes before the second
coming of Christ and you have the second
coming
it's yeah and it's on the on the
creation you know God made the waters he
separated the waters and there's a
plague that comes on the waters and as
hail in the air I mean it's just all the
things you see in creation are under
attack there in Revelation friends I
don't think we have time for another
question matter of fact I hope we have
time for you to tell me to share with
you thanks so much for listening
God willing we're gonna be studying his
word again together next week don't
forget please go to amazing facts
amazing facts idato RG if you like the
program click and donate thank you
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
journey back through time to the center
of the universe discover how a perfect
angel transformed into Satan the arch
villain the birth of evil a rebellion in
heaven
a mutiny that moved to earth
behold the creation of a beautiful new
planet and the first humans witness the
temptation and even discover God's
amazing plan to save his children this
is a story that involves every life on
earth every life the cosmic conflict if
God is good if God is all-powerful if
God is love then what went wrong
[Music]
find out what the critics are raving
about top scholars and theologians from
around the country come together to
reveal the hidden history of the book of
Revelation with powerful reenactments
and incredible visual effects this 95
minute masterpiece brings to life the
book of Revelation like never before
revelation is no longer a mystery get
your copy today visit iTunes or AF
bookstore calm
written by the hand of God and spoken
with his voice
some words will never fade
yet pastor Doug bachelors twelve part
sermon series on the Ten Commandments by
calling 805 three eight seven two seven
five or visit AF bookstore calm deep
within the pages of the Bible stories of
great heroes heroes of great deeds great
love
and great sacrifice but behind them is
another hero hidden in plain sight amid
the shadows he was there from the
beginning
and he'll be there until the end
discover the golden thread of a savior
woven throughout the entire bible
tapestry shadows of light seeing Jesus
in all the Bible get your copy today by
calling 855-578-6767
[Music]
to take advantage of the offers you've
heard on this broadcast call us at
[Music]